elon musk is the world's richest man and
many people think maybe he just got
lucky maybe he doesn't really know what
he's doing doesn't sound that smart when
he's tweeting out memes and various
emojis on twitter right wrong elon musk
is obviously incredibly intelligent he
also works very hard in a recent
interview he talked about the difficulty
with sleeping it's not what you would
think it's not that he doesn't know how
to go to sleep or that he can't sleep
really well during the middle of the
night instead he talked about the fact
that there's an opportunity cost every
hour that he sleeps means that his
companies aren't getting better he has
broken down the math to the point where
he knows that every single minute he
spends in high quality thought can have
an impact of up to a million dollars on
the financial performance of tesla
that's an absolutely incredible point
listen to exactly what elon says here in
this interview question i mean does that
how do you handle that psychologically
there aren't many people in the world
who have to even think about that i i
actually don't think about that too much
but the
the the thing that is actually more more
difficult and and that does make
sleeping difficult is
that um you know every good hour
uh or even minute of thinking about uh
tesla
and spacex has such a big effect on the
company that i really try to work as as
much as possible uh you know to the edge
of sanity basically uh because the you
know tesla's getting to the point where
probably we'll get to the point later
this year where
every good every high quality minute of
thinking
is a million dollars to
impact on on tesla so
uh
which is insane um
so
um i mean the basic you know if tesla is
doing you know of a
sort of two billion dollars a week let's
say in revenues sort of 300
million dollars a day
seven days a week you know it's
if you can change that by five percent
in an hour's brainstorm um
that those those are very valuable
that's a pretty valuable hour i mean
there are many many instances where uh
a half hour meeting the finance i was
able to improve the financial outcome of
the company um by a hundred million
dollars in a half hour meeting it's
pretty crazy to think about elon having
a million dollar impact on tesla just
for one minute of thinking it's
obviously because he's acquired just so
much leverage tesla is the only american
car company that has been able to
actually withstand all the pressures of
building a car company from scratch but
he also is the one that is thriving the
most tesla is valued more than all other
american car companies combined but to
then see that elon has the data point
he's seen historically the fact that a
30-minute meeting could have a 100
million dollar impact on the company
sleeping is important making sure that
he can think clearly is even more
important and ultimately we are watching
elon musk the world's greatest
entrepreneur
and the world's richest man lay out
exactly what goes through his head make
sure you're paying attention because
sometimes working hard is important and
other times working smart is important
we combine working hard with working
smart and you put it behind the work of
a man like elon musk he quite literally
can create an inflection point humanity
that's pretty damn cool that we're all
alive to watch this happen hey you did
you like this video great we make five
of them a day and post them here on this
channel make sure you subscribe like the
video and see you next time